II like how did you know that you were a
filmmaker and not a film watcher oh
that's a really good question Cisco
state maybe I don't know enough about
this technology maybe I should just
maybe I should go on and get a PhD like
that was something that I was seriously
considering but for whatever I don't
know how you know others then you keep
having the the drive to make something I
think that's probably the the test like
you know one of the things I tell the
students you know they they kind of
don't know what they're getting
themselves into the first time they make
even just a short film and so when it's
all over and they're stressed out and
they feel like their movies not as good
as it could have been or it's not what
they wanted to make because it's a movie
and I tell them that that's the test the
test is though you went through all that
stress
it was incredibly hectic you're
ultimately feel like the film could be
better which is what everybody thinks
after they make a movie so you're not
100% happy with the finished product but
the test is if you wake up in a couple
days or a couple weeks in a couple
months or a couple months and you want
to make something again then you want to
be a filmmaker
you know and so the drive to like oh I'm
interested in this I'm interested in
using the camera to try to I don't get
it ideas or tell stories or project some
perspective of the world if that doesn't
go away and it hasn't gone away yet
that's that's how I knew but I mean it
was there was a question I just was you
know in those moments like I was
describing where oh my god they all know
more than I do and there's something
about just filmmaking because it's so
heavily tilted towards men or guys and
they are so full of can be not all guys
can be so full of bravado and trying to
prove themselves film sets are so full
of guys trying to prove how much they
know what they've done and so that can
be really intimidating like that oh I
don't know as much as these guys they're
talking about a lens that I don't know
anything about it they're talking about
something the camera they're talking
about something with a dolly shot that I
don't know anything about and so that
can make you go okay this is not I'll
just be the guy who maybe I'll write
reviews or whatever or all I'll write a
do a dissertation on Mike Lee films
because I love Mike Lee or whatever and
but then the oh this is an idea I mean
should I should write that down
you know you start writing something
that the great thing about you know if
you if you are a like me I consider
myself like a writer director I write my
own stuff and I you know make it nobody
can stop me there's nothing stopping me
from writing a script
there's nothing styled like that doesn't
cost any money it's just my time and if
I'm I'm enjoying it and I feel like it's
interesting and it turned into something
and I can just do that and then I can
make the decision whether or not I want
to try to make it you know that I don't
know that's still that still holds a lot
of pleasure for me if it stops if it's
not it's not pleasureful anymore and
I'll stop doing it cuz filmmaking is too
hard don't think he's way too hard to do
something that's not like you're not
getting anything out of it it doesn't
feel it's not fun it doesn't feel like
you're doing anything interesting
you